it is already bitterly cold here in
beijing as they make the final
preparations for the winter olympics
everything is being checked to make sure
it goes off without a hitch
but now there is a big one and the
atmosphere has turned even icier the
biden administration will not send any
diplomatic or official representation to
the beijing 2022 winter olympics and
paralympic games given the pierre scenes
ongoing genocide and crimes against
humanity in xinjiang and other human
rights abuses we will not be
contributing to the fanfare of the games
american athletes will attend even
though officials will not this is a
diplomatic not a full sporting boycott
like we saw in the days of the cold war
u.s china ties had seemed to be thawing
with the biden administration talking
about establishing guard rails to keep
the relationship on track even as they
competed
but this will provoke rage in beijing
today the chinese government had
attacked the idea of a boycott saying
that anyway they hadn't even invited
american officials to attend
without being invited american
politicians keep hyping the so-called
diplomatic boycott of the beijing winter
olympics it seriously offends the 1.4
billion chinese people
china says the games are about the
athletes not politics but the story of
another olympian added to the pressure
for a boycott the apparent disappearance
of tennis player pong shui who said she
was sexually assaulted by a senior
communist party official provoked
western condemnation
that idea that politics and sport should
be kept separate is difficult in an
authoritarian state where everything is
political
events like this are the official
fanfare the white house was talking
about
beijing insists the olympics should just
be about the sport but it also comes
with all this pomp and ceremony right
now very senior communist party official
presiding over this ceremony supporters
of a boycott said any western
politicians who came to the games would
in effect be endorsing this government a
government they accused of multiple
human rights abuses
the question now becomes whether other
countries will follow the us in its
diplomatic boycott the british
government has not yet announced whether
it will do the same
but the temporary thor between the west
and china seems to be over
welcome to the big freeze
tom cheshire sky news beijing